إذا قدم
أي شخص تنازلاً بشأن
أوكرانيا خلف ظهر أوكرانيا
أولاً ،
فلن نقبل
أننا سنكون في
وضع بلد يلتقط
الهاتف ، فهذه تعليمات القوة
العظمى وتتبعها لا ،
لقد
دفعنا الكثير بما في ذلك  15000 حياة من مواطنينا
لتأمين الحق في تقرير
مستقبلنا ومصيرنا
، ولن نسمح لأي شخص بفرض
أي تنازلات علينا ،
لذلك عندما سمعت الأسبوع الماضي الرئيس
بايدن في ذلك المؤتمر الصحفي سيئ السمعة
يقول إن توغلًا بسيطًا
في  قد لا تجلب أوكرانيا
نوع الاستجابة السريعة الموحدة الشديدة ،
فما كان رد
فعل المسؤولين هنا ، وهل تلقيت
يومًا اعتذارًا أو مكالمة هاتفية من
البيت الأبيض أو وزارة الخارجية
لمحاولة شرح التعليقات
التي سمعناها بما قاله الرئيس بايدن
استمع البيت الأبيض والرئيس بايدن المفترض إلى ردنا على
ذلك وقمنا بلف تلك الصفحة
وسمعنا
من المسؤولين الأمريكيين الذين يتحدثون بصراحة
إلى وسائل الإعلام
ولكن أيضًا
التحدث إلي وإلى المسؤولين الأوكرانيين الآخرين
مباشرة عبر الهاتف
أن الولايات المتحدة ستظل
ملتزمة
تمامًا بقطع روسيا في حالة حدوث أي نوع من
التدخل في الغزو